The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.
If you follow politics, if you work in politics,
you report on politics, you generally understand
that every American president through foreign
policy makes decisions that lead to people
dying.
It could be a drone strike.
It could be cutting key medical aid to another
country.
It could be sending people to war.
So through foreign policy.
Presidents cause death.
That's not a new thing.
But the Trump administration has turned deadly
in a way that is different, in a way that
is much more easily preventable.
Elizabeth Drew wrote a really good article
about this for Project Syndicate, and she
points out that the Trump administration has
turned deadly simply because Donald Trump
ignored readily available advice from scientists
and other knowledgeable advisers from day
one on the issue of Corona virus.
Donald Trump was told about the risks of doing
nothing back in December and January.
And now he says, nobody knew.
Nobody could have imagined.
Trump was given the pandemic playbook by the
Obama administration, color coded 69 pages
and ignored it and now says nobody could have
expected this.
But we know intelligence agencies were warning
him.
Science agencies were warning him.
Public health agencies were telling him what
was potentially coming.
And he also had been briefed.
His administration had been briefed by the
outgoing Obama administration in 2017, unexamined
daily, how to deal with a pandemic.
And Trump never focused on it, and he always
ignored it.
He dismissed the virus.
He said it wouldn't be worse than the flu.
He said we had 15 cases, which would soon
be zero.
He bragged that nobody had died.
He said it's under control.
And of course, it was all wrong and it has
been deadly.
Trump could have just not invoked but utilized
the Defense Production Act a while ago to
force the production of much needed medical
supplies.
But he was successfully lobbied by the Chamber
of Commerce and Industry not to do that.
And so he waited and waited and we fell further
and further behind.
He didn't mobilize the federal stockpile of
ventilators and other supplies.
Later, having his son in law, Jared Kushner,
claim in dystopian fashion that the stockpile
is ours, not the states.
In a very sinister, ominous press briefing
last Thursday and all of this led to far more
death than necessary.
Trump played favorites with states regularly.
We get reports that red state governors were
getting everything they asked for in terms
of supplies and equipment.
While many blue state governors were not and
Trump continued and continues to blame systems
he inherited, which is code for blame Obama.
Trump is negotiating in some cases against
states for medical supplies that those states
need, while insisting states have to go out
and get their stuff and blaming states for
shortages that they experience.
Trump is regularly using war language to try
to weaponize the virus as a political tool
for reelection.
And so the decisions that he makes have always
been primarily influenced by political calculations
and political expediency.
And in the background of all of this.
We hear lame economic arguments made, which
essentially are arguments that say it's OK
for more people should die in exchange for
the economy.
The economy is meant to be open.
The country is meant to be open.
The cure cannot be worse than the disease
or we can't allow it to be worse than the
disease.
And of course, this ignores the reality that
from day one, if we had had a proper six week
shutdown, we would have prevented the need
for these overlapping partial shutdowns that
still are going to do economic damage, but
won't actually fix the problem once and for
all.
It's almost impossible to do a worse job than
Donald Trump did.
Many small business owners I know people who
just run a restaurant would have been able
to manage this better than Donald Trump.
Given all of the resources that he had at
his disposal, many of which he chose to ignore.
And if you want to play the business game,
any modest, humble, you know, professor I
had in business school would have been able
to manage this better than Donald Trump, because
most of peop- most people who who actually
understand business and are good at business
understand the importance of deferring to
experts, which Donald Trump seems essentially
unable to do.
Any doctor who runs a medical practice would
have managed this better than Donald Trump.
If Trump had done nothing other than to say
I'm appointing a.
Corona virus czar like Ronald Clain, maybe
Barack Obama's Ebola czar.
And just let them handle that.
Let them handle it and stayed out of it.
We would be far better off.
So, yes, presidents lead to death through
foreign policy and through domestic policy
and a lot of different ways.
But the Trump presidency has now become deadly
in a way that is very different than what
we normally say when we say presidents lead
to death through foreign policy.
It's very, very ugly and we don't yet know
how bad it's going to get.